TV uh a lot of things went well for you
today one thing that I'm a little bit
suspicious about you once again played
the
French you shouldn't do that yeah you're
my hero tat well done yaser loves it the
last time in this tournament I don't
have to see a French or a Catalan for at
least a month well you can play the
Catalan tomorrow perhaps anyway tell us
about today's game where did you feel
like you're finally taking over the
initiative and uh tell us the critical
moments
uh yeah the opening I thought went well
for me with all these pieces coming off
I thought I was comfortable I was happy
to see that she went F5 and for a
fighting position I was a little worried
she might play Knight D3 and try to play
an end game and try to be more solid
because I wasn't sure if I could try to
push that position because okay I can go
Knight E4 but maybe she can go Knight F2
I'm I'm not sure can I press here yeah
yeah yeah I mean I don't want to do this
of course so I was very happy that she
wanted to fight and you know she created
a double edge position which felt scary
for me I think objectively even during
the game I had a feeling it should be
okay for me but um you know it's a
French so you always have to think about
am I getting checkmated very good
point very good point but once my Rook
got to G6 I was safe I just thought that
I missed a nice tactic it didn't occur
to me that I had this moment but I could
have trapped the her night which is um
at what point
really uh I I think here
H5 Queen H5 F5 at some point
H5 H5 F5 the problem is The Rook on G6
right no no no The Rook but there was a
moment where I could have done
this I just checked on my phone I don't
know maybe I'm missing
okay perhaps I don't see it yeah but
once we got to the end game then I was
quite happy and the whole time again I
was telling myself you're up a pawn
don't lose control somehow you'll
convert and I think that today I didn't
really give her any chances absolutely
and you did convert quite successfully
after that you're still in the fight for
the podium and uh that's a big fight
because both Alis Le and Arena Crush
have won their respective games today
what do you have to do tomorrow to uh
finish on the
podium well I'm playing Arena so I have
my chances there I'm playing with the
white pieces I mean historically she's
been a very difficult opponent for me
well she's been a difficult opponent for
everyone here uh but I do have the white
pieces um and she's also fighting for
third place so she will definitely try
to beat me but Alice is um I don't know
who she's playing but okay that one is
out of my control but I think I have my
fifth place guaranteed so I don't really
have much to lose MoneyWise but I can
try to fight for a higher place of
course but T didn't you play Arena crash
few years back in the US championships
also in the last round also with white
pieces and then managing to
win I I think I won last year against
her if I'm not
mistaken in the last round with the
white P I don't
remember too many games that may still a
big game that's going to be a big game T
go get your rest get your preparation in
big game tomorrow and uh we'll see you
tomorrow thank you our congratulations
to you as well t